I'm not gonna make a face like I can't hack for less than three hours.
Are you kidding me right now, dude?
Like you telling me that you never you very rarely hack for longer than three hour contiguous periods.
Yeah, that's that's pretty like I get tired.
Oh my God.
My eyes hurt, man.
What's up, y'all?
Before we hop into this episode today, I just wanted to give a little bit of an introduction.
We were graced by the magnificent presence of Mr. Douglas Day, aka Archangel on the episode today.
Joel and I know Douglas from the live hacking event community where we have competed against him and collaborated with him many times.
So it was a pleasure to have him on the pod.
Douglas is known for a couple things in the live hacking event community.
The primary of which is his collaboration abilities.
Douglas almost always collaborates with other hackers on the live hacking event scene.
And he has taken home nine best collaboration awards over his time at the live hacking events.
So a very impressive number.
He's also known specifically for his volume of reports that he submits.
He finds a lot of bugs and has really dialed in radar for what is a bug and what's not a bug to a company.
And he also has a lot of I guess he has a very methodical approach to bug bounty.
He has a lot of methods, techniques that he uses that work really well for him and get good results.
So for those of you that are a little bit more method oriented, I think this will be a great episode for you.
All right.
I think that's it.
So without further ado, enjoy the episode.
Boom.
We're rolling.
Douglas, welcome to the pod, man.
Thanks.
Good to be here.
So I guess we'll start out today.
We've got to warm up.
Got to warm up our podcasting voices, our podcasting element.
I work on my radio voice.
Yep.
This guy's got it already.
Let's start off.
Why don't you tell us a little bit about how you got into InfoSec and how you eventually got into Book Bounties?
Because right now you're on the program side as well as on the hacker side, right?
More or less.
Yeah.
I spend less time on the program side these days.
However, I am associated with the Elastic program.
So although I'm less and less active as the days go on.
Is your role just shifting with that or is it?
Yeah.
I do a lot more infrastructure side security.
So working on like Terraform, Kubernetes, sort of running our InfoSec infrastructure.
And I passed on the bug bounty to our product security team.
So, but we can get into that a bit later.
Yeah.
So tell me about how you landed this position at Elastic and work back in your InfoSec history.
I'll work backwards.
That's probably a good way to go.
So back in 2020, I was the number one hacker on the Elastic bug bounty program.
It was a very small program then.
I think we were offering like 1k crits.
And for a very complicated tech stack like Elastic, that's pretty suboptimal.
But I was the number one hacker nonetheless.
And then around the turn of the turn of the new year, they're looking for someone to run
the bug bounty program.
And they thought, why not take our number one hacker and have him build up the program?
So I applied, threw in my hat to the application process and landed the job and then built out
the bug bounty program over Elastic.
And then we launched about two years later.
And I think we had like the sixth most active bug bounty launch on the hacker one platform.
Oh, nice.
So yeah, we saw a, we had a very, very wide scope to start.
And so we saw a lot of submissions.
But yeah, it was, it was a pretty successful launch.
But then moving backwards, this was goodness.
This is 2020, like the dawn of 2020.
And I started my bug bounty career.
The year of darkness.
Yeah.
The year that everything changed.
Right.
I know.
But, but I started bug bounty about two years before that, in October of, or I guess about
a year and a half before that, in October of 2018.
Nice.
I'd gone to, I'd gone to B-Sides Portland in which Ben Sadiqapur and the Homestack was running
a, a, what do you call it?
A presentation at B-Sides.
And I was like, Oh, Hey, that looks, that looks pretty fun.
I started my hacker one account that evening and they got my first bounty about two months
later.
Dude.
Yeah.
So Ben is, Ben is a part of your origin story, huh?
He is.
Right off the bat at that, at that, at that conference.
And that's how you weaseled your way into bug bounty.
Yeah.
And so it was kind of a, it was pretty slow.
It's slow at the start.
Um, I didn't expect to be part of like the, the community like I am today.
I didn't expect to ever be participating in live events.
Um, but about a year after I started, I created my account.
I remember getting my very first life hacking event invite.
I was, I was at the gym.
I was about to start a workout in the morning over at 24 hour fitness.
And I get like an email.
It's like, and this is like, shoot, this is like mid July.
And so like the, uh, I was definitely a last minute addition.
Like I didn't, I didn't try to get an invite or anything.
I think somebody dropped them.
So I got a 702 invite for, uh, for 2019.
Nice dude.
For 2019 Vegas.
And I was like, Oh, what is this?
You know, what is, what is live hacking event?
What is the Duke window?
I don't know.
Um, so I, I showed up and I remember, I think I was talking to, uh, I show up and not knowing
what to expect.
Um, very first life event.
I think I, I mistakenly didn't realize the value of the Duke window.
And so I spent maybe like two hours in the Duke window hacking and then thought I would
do all my hacking at the, yeah, at the, at the event itself.
Okay.
For those of you that aren't familiar with live hacking event structure.
So typically how it works, there's a, uh, before the live hacking event, there is a, uh, a window,
you know, normally something like a week and a half, two weeks, maybe sometimes of, um, period
where you can, where everyone's hacking on the target.
Everyone knows the scope.
Everyone knows the policy, everything like that.
Um, but during that period, if you find any bugs that anyone else has, has found and you submit them,
then those dupes get split.
So what Douglas is saying here is that he didn't hack at all during this period where he was
supposed to be hacking and prepping.
Um, and because of that, he probably lost himself the opportunity to, uh, get in on a bunch of bugs that he would
have otherwise found and split those, you know, some of those low hanging fruits that other, other hackers
will find get split the bounties on those.
Is that, does that, did I summarize that well enough?
Yeah.
That's pretty, that's pretty accurate.
So I came into the deep window with like one event and I remember showing up to the, to the welcome party.
I think it was at Topgolf that year.
And, um, I was like,
No, that was, I missed, I wanted to go to that so bad.
Oh yeah.
No, that's too bad.
I was flying in and I was on the plane and then like a sandstorm hit and it had to defer to a different airport.
And I missed your first live hacking event, you know,
Sandstorm.
That's crazy.
So sad.
Yeah.
But so, but so I'm there and I'm like talking with other people.
I have no idea who these, who these people are by their face, but I think like, I think like peer Luke,
uh, you know, a Ram sexy like came up to be, and he was like, so, so who are you?
And I wasn't even asked, like, so how did you get invited to this?
No, not, not, not, it doesn't mean he was being mean or anything, but like, I wasn't the plus one.
I didn't know.
I didn't know anybody else.
And I was kind of like a, a nobody like hacker.
I was kind of, I don't, I have no idea how I got invited.
I would just say like a random last minute addition.
And so I knew no one.
Um, but I had a, had a great time at the event learned, okay, you actually use the dupe window to hack.
But, uh, most importantly, I made a couple of, of good connections, uh, who then plus one to me to the Los Angeles event a couple months later.
And then after that, I've sort of been on the, been on the live event train for the last four years or three years, four years.
Yeah.
Yeah, man.
It's a ride, man.
It really is.
Um, so, I mean, you, you got, you went to that Los Angeles live hacking event.
And is that when the sort of collaboration train started, you know, from, from those connections you made and then you started collaborating every single event?
Cause that's, I mean, that's your go-to MO now, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
So, so I was a plus one, um, and given, you know, given this was my second, so the LA event was my very second event, I still wasn't exactly sure how they were supposed to work.
Um, and so I, I was a Hogarth 45 plus one to that event.
Um, and I was like, Hey, since I'm a plus one, I assumed that since I was a plus one, we'd have to team up.
And so, and he was, he was chill with it.
And then, uh, I don't remember why, but we wanted to have like a, a more, like a bigger team.
And so I think we grabbed, we grabbed Grim Sexy and we grabbed, uh, Mr. Tux Racer, uh, for our, for our team.
Yeah.
And so we just kind of went ham.
I think it was Air Force that time.
Um, uh, it was, yeah, Air Force and Verizon Media.
And we just went, went ham on them.
And we were, we were a bit salty because this was before the best collaboration award was a thing.
I think they started it like the following event or the after.
And so we like obliterated as a team, um, and would have, would have gotten the best team award at that award existed at the time.
But, uh, but no, it was, it was a, it was a great event.
We, you know, we, we did really well.
And then subsequent events, I've just kind of gotten invited, uh, uh, over and over again, fortunately.
And, um, yeah, I had such a fun time.
Um, just kind of collabing, uh, during the, during the due point of this time, uh, you know, hopping on video calls, uh, sharing ideas, just kind of hanging out, talking about life or whatever with the guys.
And, uh, I've just kind of haven't, haven't gone back.
Um, that's kind of how I've done most, most subsequent events.
I have a number of events, like one or two where I wasn't really, I didn't, I think some of the virtual ones where I didn't, I didn't collab as much.
Um, but for, for every event that I've been to in person, I've, I've for sure tried to, tried to team up with, with one to four other hackers, I suppose.
Yeah.
I think it's always, it's really interesting to see how collabing has changed over the years in live hacking events.
I think in the beginning, like there was very little collaboration that was done and it was very like only like tightly knit groups of people or like people who like were used to hacking with each other.
And now I feel like everybody collabs with everybody.
Like there's a lot more knowledge sharing and a lot more like open collaboration, that kind of stuff nowadays.
Um, there, there is.
Yeah.
So when you're collaborating, would you say it's mostly like the same people or do you split it up or?
I think more, more or less the same people.
I guess I just like collaborating with people that I, that I know and that I'm, that I'm already friends with.
Uh, every once in a while, like call, want to collab with someone, but they'll also want to collab with someone else.
And so we'll bring them in and then, you know, that person becomes a, becomes a friend of mine, but I've got a number of regulars, like, uh, all the, all the French Canadians, almost all the French Canadians I've collabed with.
Like I've collabed with DC.
I've collabed with, uh, Pure Luke.
I've collabed with, uh, Sebastian.
I've collabed with, uh, J, uh, J rock 17 now.
Um, so a bunch of French Canadians.
I've collabed with Alves Chapman a lot.
I've collabed with res zero a lot.
Um, space raccoon, um, core backs even.
Um, so there's been a, a number of, a number of, uh, hackers that I've, I've kind of worked.
Oh, today's new has been a, been a common, a common thread.
Um, who's saying, I mean, I could go on and on it more, more.
Yeah.
The more I think about it.
Well, at the, at the most recent live hacking events, I've kind of seen you with the group with, of Rezo and, and Alex Chapman.
And, uh, and that, that seems to be a pretty, a pretty functional group that you guys have, have held across a couple live hacking events.
And I, I noticed, you know, one of the, one of the main problems that I have with collaboration, because, um, both, both, um, Joel and I, uh, were a part of disturbance, right?
Which was a, a giant hacking team, uh, that we had going on for a little while.
But, um, you know, kind of the ways that the way that we saw that, or the way that it worked, worked out was, you know, there was so much variation in how everyone would perform at the live hacking events.
Right.
So if you, if you, if you performed well, and then you, then you were losing money a lot of the time.
But if you performed poorly, you were feeling like you were dragging your friends down.
Right.
So the only times that it, you know, so those are both, both negative outcomes for, for me, this is why I rarely collab at live hacking events anymore beyond, you know, or at least not full split collabs.
Um, and, and, and the only scenario when it really works out well, if for, for me is when we both add equal value and it just kind of edges out and, you know, we both have, have fun with it.
Right.
Um, and, and Joel and I were able to pull that off a live hacking event, uh, you know, earlier this year.
Um, and that was great.
But, um, so my question to you is like, how do you deal with the, that up and down of collaboration?
And how do you, how do you communicate with your, your longterm collaboration partners to make that work?
Yeah.
So I should purpose this by saying I've been to a lot of events.
I think that if, if a live event was something that I knew it was going only going to happen once, then I'd have a lot more to lose.
Um, but goodness after 15 live events, I've been the, the under contributor on some I've been the over contributor on some, and there have been some where it's been kind of been kind of in the middle.
Um, and I think that the, the sting of under contributing and the sting of losing money because you were an over contributor.
They, they both sting less than the sting of showing up to an event by yourself empty handed.
And so I think, I think, uh, collabing and guaranteeing like decent success because you've, you've got a solid team.
Even if you might under contribute and feel like, uh, uh, you know, a bozo or you over contribute and feel like you lost some money.
Um, in the end it's basically guaranteeing, you know, it's, it's, I guess, uh, hedging your risks.
It's, um, you know, kind of like diversifying your, your bug bounty portfolio in a way.
Um, and so over the course of many events, I think it, it kind of averages out.
If you have a, if you have somebody who's like consistently underachieving, whether because they, they maybe aren't up to the team.
Maybe aren't up to skill with live hacking events or are just not, uh, trying, then you can kind of like start to see those out over the course of time.
But I don't know, like the amount of fun I have with, with bug bounty events and the, the value I get just being a part of the community is, is worth the, you know, couple of live events where maybe I, I lose like, you know, a few thousand dollars due to just over contributing.
Where it's like, and I think another part of it is it's really, really hard to, yeah, it's, it's really hard to quantify the value.
Like the, it's really hard to quantify the value that collaboration brings.
Cause there's been a number of times where I've been collaborating with someone who didn't submit, who themselves didn't submit a lot of bugs.
But I, all of my bugs were because of a something that they, that they sent in discord or, or slack or whatever, you know, maybe they were like looking, maybe they were looking at some domain that I didn't realize was in scope.
And then because they were looking at that domain, I found a link to another domain, which was super vulnerable.
And I submitted tons of bugs on that.
And it's like, okay, I'm the one that's that found all these bugs, but would I have found it?
I don't know.
And so it's, it's really hard to quantify like how much just being a part of the, of the collaboration process, adds to the, adds to the team.
And so maybe, maybe I'll figure out a way to, to add a dollar value to it.
But I haven't reached that point yet.
Yeah.
I've, I've, I've really noticed that a lot with like, so when, when events first went virtual, um, after in person, it was very difficult.
I feel like at least for me to like, try and get that sense of like collaboration that you get at events.
And I think a lot of it boils down to what you were talking about there, where it's not so much like that person submitted so many bugs or whatever.
It's that the combined brain power of the people in the room is working towards like a singular goal.
And so if you have five people looking at the same thing, there's so much, so many more minds and threads thinking about that bug and how to be creative with it at the same time that make it so much easier to find impactful vulnerabilities when you're working as a group.
Um, absolutely.
And there's not an easy way to like measure that.
Right.
Like you said, like, just because they didn't submit a vulnerability doesn't mean that they didn't contribute significantly.
To that vulnerability.
Just if you know, they're a collaborator on it, whatever that, that doesn't really get accounted for super well.
Um, and so I think like that whole aspect of it is very interesting.
I'm curious, especially, it seems like a lot of the people you work with are not people who are local to you.
So are there certain things that you do when you're collaborating to help aid with that collaboration?
I know for Justin and I was very, very helpful for us to basically just be in a call all day, like all day, every day while we were hacking together.
12 hour discord call.
Yeah.
And that basically like creating sort of that same environment where you're like next to each other, kind of you're all looking, you're like both looking at the same thing.
You're, you know, both your minds are working on the same thing together, that, that type of stuff.
Do you have any tricks that you use?
Yeah.
So I also do video calls, video calls or audio calls.
And it's, it's so nice just to, um, set one up, even if you're not talking that whole time, just to be like, Oh wait, I think I found something.
And then the other person kind of sidetracked what they're working on and help you just decide whether or not it's a, it's like a true positive or a false positive.
And sometimes it's not, and you just go back to working, but just having, having that sort of desk buddy, um, just on the other side of the screen is, is super, super helpful.
Um, and that's been, that's been where we've found some of our, some of our coolest, our coolest bugs when we were just, uh, working together on a zoom call.
And then someone found something that was interesting and then we all just kind of dogpiled on it and then boom.
Uh, so I think I'm, I may sound a little bit like a negative Nancy with collaboration.
Like I love collaboration.
I really do.
But here's the other thing with that, right?
Like, and I don't always mean to be bringing up the cons, but you know, I gotta do it.
So like in those situations, Joel and I, um, we were pair hacking pretty much, uh, during this live hacking event by the nature of what the target was and the way we were doing it.
So we, we, it wasn't the two of us going down and, and looking at, you know, different routes and, and that sort of thing.
And then comparing notes, it was both of us looking at one screen saying, okay, what if we did this?
What if we did that?
You know, that's one thing.
And it worked out great.
The, but in the past I've done the route that you guys sort of just described of like both being on a video call, working on your own things and then pulling people in when you need them.
Um, and it really, I guess it just depends on the person.
Right.
But like, sometimes you get that person that's like, Hey, look at this every like five minutes.
And it's like, like, I can't think because I, as soon as I get in my flow state, you know, it's, I can't, you know, I get pulled out and pulled into something else.
So I feel like I'm, I'm more becoming like a support hacker rather than, you know, somebody who's trying to find his own, his own bug.
So, I mean, I guess, I don't know if I want to put you on the spot and say, like, have you ever experienced that with, you know, the people you've collaborated with, but what, what's your thoughts on the way we could deal with that collaboration little mishap?
Yeah.
So, I mean, that does happen to me.
I think I, um, I don't think either way is, is wrong or right.
I think that I've, I've been in, there've been times where I've been like in a flow state and like, maybe like res zero has been, been just kind of like taking a more like wide scope and be like, Oh, this thing's interesting.
And, you know, just slaps in like a buzz or a buff result into discord, you know, something that's not even an application, but might look interesting.
And I'll be like, okay, I'll, I'll, I'll just have to be like, okay, I'm going to, you know, I'm going to hop off the call for, for 20 minutes, 30 minutes, whatever.
While I, while I dig into this or, and he, he, I guess we, we worked together enough that he can kind of know when I'm in a, like, I'm, I'm focused on a, on a bug.
And, uh, maybe, maybe it's just kind of having that, having that relationship where he doesn't take offense.
If I'm like, okay, I'm, I'm, I need to focus on this.
Um, and then he'll, he'll usually be like, Hey, you, you, you focus on that.
I'll, I'll, I'll dig it.
I'll dig deeper.
And it hasn't, I could see, I could see it being coming like a problem.
If I was working with someone I hadn't worked with before and I didn't have that rapport and respect to be able to kindly, but, but, uh, reasonably be like, I need to, I need to focus for.
I need to focus for a few minutes.
It sounds like good.
It sounds like good boundaries, you know, in hacking, right?
You know, you're saying, okay, you know what?
At the end of the day, I think this is counterproductive right now.
So I'm going to say, Hey, I'm going to mute this channel for five minutes, you know, while everyone's doing the recon dump or, or hop off this call and just like put on some, you know, whatever alpha neural beats or whatever those are that like makes your brain go into focus mode and that sort of thing.
Um, and then, you know, you can, you can make it happen as long as you're communicating well with your, with your collaborators.
So I don't know, man, maybe I just wasn't, maybe I just wasn't, you know, my communication game wasn't on fleek in the past.
Well, I, I, again, I don't think there's a, I don't think there's a right, the wrong way to do it.
I'm actually entertaining the idea of trying the next several events, uh, just solo to see, to see what I can do.
Cause I think there's, there's several ways to do collab.
There's the cloud that, that I do and that I usually do, which is just, you know, full on team collab, split everything.
We're just going to act as a, act as a unit.
Um, but then there's, uh, people like, um, like I think the way you sort of do collab and the way like Nagly might do collab is, you know, go solo.
And then if you have, if you need help on a specific thing, pull in somebody.
Um, and that's, that's potentially a way to go.
There's also hackers like, um, I can't think of anybody in particular that are just, you know, radio silent and no one knows what they're hacking on.
And then they come to the event with, you know, 40 criticals and you're like, where were you, where, where were you hacking this whole, this whole event?
So maybe that, maybe that's a fun way to try out.
I'm not, I'm not, uh, I know I've kind of got this, uh, this, uh,
uh, uh, reputation of being, you know, a full team collaborator, but I'm, I'm open to trying other, other things.
And I might, I might do something new this year.
So for this upcoming year, so we'll see.
Yeah.
I mean, it's really, it's really interesting to hear like both sides of it.
I think, I think for Justin, especially it's a little bit different because you do this like full time for your main income.
Like this is your full time living.
And so the whole money splitting aspect is a little bit different.
And I think what I've found over the years of doing collaboration is one of the best ways you can do collaborations.
Just be explicit about whether or not you're working together on something like, it's fine to work in the same space and like bounce ideas off each other or throw interesting things in the chat.
But if somebody like dives into a hole, like, you know, unless they're, yeah, unless they're asking for help, like, yeah, you can maybe insert yourself in there, but unless they're like, kind of like, it's open-ended, like, you know, that's kind of their book.
And then on the other side of it, it's like, you can ask, you can be like, Hey, do you want to dive in on this together?
Like, this is pretty interesting.
Come take a look at this.
And like, then you, you know, I think that's fair game for you guys to like count that as like working together on something.
But otherwise I think there is still like that sense of, um, like working together.
There's like a whole concept of this for ADHD, where I think it's, I forget what it's called specifically, but it's like buddy, like working with a buddy and just like simply the presence of someone else doing work at the same time as you are helps you be more productive because you feel like you're like doing stuff together and like, there's more judgment if you're like not on task and all that kind of stuff.
And so that aspect of literally just like being in a video call, even if you're not working together, I think adds a lot to the productivity and the ability to like work together and have those collaboration moments, even if you're not explicitly working together all the time on everything.
Yeah, I can totally, I can totally see that.
And I do want to sort of plus one what you said about, I think it depends on your, on your stage of life and what you're like, how you treat bug bounty.
Like for me as somebody with a, with a full-time job, like bug bounty money is kind of like monopoly money at this point.
It just feels like prizes and it's cool.
Whereas if it was, if it was what I was buying my groceries with or buying, you know, my podcasting equipment with, it would feel, it would feel, uh, I would probably be much more conscientious of how it was, how it was split and spent.
Yeah. Yeah. And because of that, you know, when, when I've done collabs in the past, I've been like, Hey, especially with hackers, I respect like Joel.
I've been like, Hey, you know, I'd like to collab.
I'd even potentially be down to do a full split collab.
Um, but we have to be putting in similar time investments because if I'm putting in 50, 60 hours a week and you know, you're putting in 15 to 20 because you've got a full-time job.
Right. And I'm not going to blame you for not putting in 50, 60 hours a week when you've got a full-time job. Um, you know, then, then that's gonna, that's not gonna even out very well.
Um, and so, uh, I've always just kind of been explicit with people and, and, and, and I do like the approach as well of like, of like having.
Um, you're right here I am again, bringing the negative Nancy shit up, but the, like the chat where you like throw interesting stuff in and stuff like that.
But, but here's the problem with that for me.
Right. Is that let's say I find, I find, uh, a, an endpoint and I fully exploit that endpoint.
Right. And, um, and I, I had like maybe dropped it in the chat, but no one's around.
And then they hadn't, they hadn't seen it. And then I go back and I was like, oh, I, you know, I fully exploited it. Right.
But then that time somebody else, somebody else on the team had seen it. And, and now I, if I'm sort of, you know, they say, okay, how's that going?
It's like, oh, I popped it. I'm good. You know, right now I've sort of robbed them of the opportunity to, to exploit that endpoint had they found it themselves. Right.
So this information trading thing is really, really, really tricky. Right.
And like, like you said, you know, you don't have to be when you're doing this for fun, right.
Which some of us are, even though it's big dollars, you know, uh, it's not as intense. Right.
But when you're doing this professionally and you're, you know, a professional live hacking event competitor, right.
Then, um, these things get a little bit dicier.
Um, so I mean, what, what do you guys think about that? Do you think I'm being a little too uptight about that or what?
No, I mean, it's, it's really case by case, right?
Like there are, there are, there are so many case like edge cases that are really difficult.
And I think just having good communication in those moments and just like being like, the conversation is not going to be necessarily fun because it's like kind of about money and it's a little bit sensitive and all that kind of stuff.
But I think just being upfront and honest and like trying to meet in the middle somewhere, like wherever it makes sense, not necessarily in the middle, but wherever it makes sense, then I think that that's, you know, just going with best intent.
Right.
Yeah.
What do you think?
So a bit, a bit tangential, but one thing that I've found that works outside of the context of live events is, um, so it's doing, um, like scope splitting.
So to give you an example, a couple of months back, um, I was in a private, uh, hacker one challenge for the department of defense, uh, with, uh, res zero.
And I had been going really, really hard.
I got invited like a couple of days before he did.
And I got, I had been going really hard on one particular application, um, out of this, out of the entire scope.
And he joins and we want to club together.
And I'm like, look, man, I already tour, you know, asset a up entirely.
I'm happy to collab with you.
You know, you've already started working on asset B.
I'm happy to collaborate with you.
How about we just, you stay off of asset A, I'll stay up with asset B.
Cause you're already starting to go down that drain.
And then everything else we split.
Um, and it, it ended up working pretty well.
Like I felt like I was able to, you know, tear up my, uh, my scope item that I, that I had already gone very deep on.
And I got to, I got to know, and then he was able to, to do the same with kind of some of, some of his, uh, uh, some, uh, some of his scope.
Although he got a bit of a later start than I did.
And then we split everything else.
And it was very lucrative for, uh, for both of us.
And that saves him time too, because he's not going and duping at you on asset A.
Yes.
When we're not in the live hacking event scene, the collaboration thing is very different because at the end of the day, whoever submits the report gets the, gets the bounty, you know?
Yeah.
And so, uh, in the, in those sorts of situations, it's, it's a little bit easier, but the, the, the, the split, the split scope thing, I think is, I think that's a, that's a good shot.
And I think it can definitely work in some scenarios.
Yeah.
Cool.
Okay.
That's collabing.
I feel like we've, we've covered that.
So I did want, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You can't just pull me off.
I got, I got, I got, I got questions for days.
All right, fine.
Go ahead.
But if I let you, if I let you keep going, we're going to spend an hour talking about collabing.
So we do, we do want to talk to Douglas about a couple of other things.
Okay.
And one of those things is this tweet thread that you did.
I think this was just a March or May, right?
May of this year.
Yeah.
This is great.
I think you had this.
Yeah.
It was called, um, a hundred very short bug bounty rules and it's basically just a thread.
I don't know if this was a brain dump or if you had pre-planned this, maybe you could tell
us a little bit about how you came up with this.
But I think it's a great concept and it was basically just like a list.
A list of a hundred things, um, that you should sort of probably be doing when you're doing
bug bounty.
And these are, these range from little tidbits of you should use burp suite pro to, um, really
in-depth stuff.
Like, so why, why don't you walk us through a little bit about what sort of spurred you
to do this and what the process was like and all that.
So kind of a, kind of a funny story there.
So I, uh, I'm a fan of, of this, uh, the stoic author Ryan holiday, been reading his
stuff for, for a few years and he had put out this like a hundred very short, you know,
stoic rules for life.
And it was, it was a great thread.
Um, I like, I think I liked it and retweeted it or whatever.
Um, and then, uh, Rez0, Joseph decided, like, I guess he follows him as well.
And then made some like, uh, like a mirror tweet and it was like 10 very short bug bounty
And I was so like frustrated that yeah, that he only did 10.
Only 10.
I'm like, come on, if you're going to copy something like as beautiful as this, it, it
needs to be done like the right way.
And so like out of spite, I was just like, no, I'm going to do a hundred just to show
you that it can be done.
And so I think I spent like, I didn't use like chat GPT or anything.
I just spent probably like 90 minutes, um, in the late afternoon, just like typing, like
typing them up as fast as I could.
And I tried to, I tried to have a mix of like more like philosophical behavioral like tips
as well as technique, like technical tips.
Cause not everyone wants just to have your, uh, you know, don't stop trying or, uh, if you're
having a hard time, just take a break.
You know, that's kind of like, kind of gets dried and exhausting.
Um, but also, you know, coming up with a hundred, uh, uh, technical like bug bounty tips would
be extremely difficult.
Uh, also my AirPods are going to die soon.
So I might have switched to my Mac book speakers or my book.
If that's the, if that's the case, we can, we can cut the audio and reset it back up.
But I really enjoyed this, this whole long tweet.
And I appreciate also that you did a hundred of them because like, I don't know, I've not,
I haven't done much content creating before I started this podcast.
And then I've started doing some content stuff since then.
Um, it's freaking hard, my dude.
It is very challenging to like, come up with all the content and stuff like that.
You need to, you know, to run a successful, you know, to do a good tweet that, that gets
good take off with the community and stuff like that.
So I definitely appreciate this.
And, and, uh, but you know, I had a couple of questions about some of these that I, and that
I wanted to kind of dive into.
Okay.
Yes, let's do it.
All right.
So number one, starting off right at the very beginning, it's a very good place to start.
Um, you say spend at least 30 minutes on a new target.
Okay.
Um, and then you say later, later on, give yourself a no bug time.
This is on, uh, item number 15, give yourself a no bug time limit.
I do three hours.
So, um, for, for me, I'm one of those people that it takes me a little bit more time to
start finding bugs on a, on an application normally.
Um, so I'm, I'm wondering how you reconcile these two and what that first 30 minutes looks
like versus the, the first three hours.
Yep.
Yeah.
So the first 30 minutes, I kind of go into this on my, in the homestack talk, but I basically
go, assuming it's a SAS application, which is where I spend most of my time.
I go straight to user management and I look, okay, how many different types of users are there?
Is there like, just like two, if that's the case, then there's probably not going to be
as many bugs that, that sort of fit my, my flavor.
Um, or are there, uh, uh, you know, three custom roles where you can like make a, have
like an entire, like matrix of, okay, this user, you can give them this permission, but
not this permission.
And then you can have an admin role that has every single permission except for this permission.
And then, uh, just like the more complicated, the, the role structure, the, the more confident
I'm going to be that there's going to be bugs.
So first 30 minutes, the straight to user management, and especially like the, the user invite, uh,
flow because that's where I find most of my criticals, um, and, and higher, higher security bugs.
Like if I can, if I can invite myself to someone else's organization, okay, it's like, it's been critical.
If I can invite myself, uh, if I can invite myself as another user, but who has higher permissions,
it's like, okay, that's, that's at least a high.
Um, a lot of your, a lot of your methodology, and I believe I even saw it in that tweet, but
a lot of your methodology is built around, uh, this whole piece of user off matrices and like,
you know, organization and stuff like that.
And I think that's really good.
And I think that's awesome to have a bread and butter like that.
And certainly I think in the last life hacking, I guess the last one that I really participated in, um, in London, you know,
you know, I saw your, some of your brilliance with that, right.
With your, the way you get the apps fully configured and the way you kind of come up with these really crazy attack scenarios.
And I really appreciated that, but I'm wondering how you approach, how you approach applications that don't have this.
So in that first 30 minutes, would you say if you came to an application that doesn't have user roles and stuff like that,
are you moving along to and checking all the other targets before you come back?
Well, probably, I think it also depends on how complex the application is.
I think my other sort of, uh, type of bug is, um, like business logic errors.
And so maybe it's an application where, uh, there's going to be a lot, lots of bugs having to do with just bypassing logic that the, that's very unique to that application.
Maybe it's a, uh, for example, I think you tweeted about this not too long ago, but maybe it's an application that has lots of like levels of subscriptions.
And so that's lots of opportunities for paywall bypasses, right?
Yeah.
Like if, if you can buy, if you can make a, like a business level subscription, which gives you access to features ABC, but then also an enterprise level, uh, application, which gives you access to, you know, features XYZ.
Then I tried to, okay, as a, as a free trial, can I get access to business level as a business level?
Can I get access to enterprise level features?
Um, and then oftentimes if the program is very good, every single feature that I can, that I can get access to is a, is a separate bug.
Um, especially if I can find one that, uh, where the paywall is actually enforced, because then I have evidence that, um, that it wouldn't be a single fix.
Like for example, if, if I can, uh, if as a business level user, I can't get access to enterprise feature X, but I can get access to enterprise features Y and Z.
It's like, okay, uh, Y and Z are going to be separate bugs because if they're the same bug, then I wouldn't be able to, then I would, should also be able to get access to X, but I can't.
Yeah.
So I, yeah, so like business logic and, um, or yeah, yeah, business logic bugs are kind of my second go to after, after user, uh, authorization bugs.
Nice.
That's really cool.
So we, I mean, I don't want to go through like all of these.
So maybe this is a good time to talk a little bit about methodology since we're kind of already on that, on that route.
So can you walk us through sort of how you approach a new target?
Cause you're always hacking and like, I think it's really impressive to see how quickly you hop onto a program or are able to just like find bugs and navigate it and get it mapped out super quickly.
So how, what's sort of, what's your approach?
Like what's your general approach look like?
Yeah.
So one of my secrets is that I actually spend a lot of time on very small programs.
Um, I think it's kind of, there's a lot of hackers that go after those really, really big ones, like, like Shopify or, uh, or I'm trying to think of public programs.
If I can talk about, uh, PayPal, um, uh, GitHub, uh, you know, these, these large programs that pay very large, large criticals and large mediums and large highs.
Um, but I'd say maybe like over 50% of my bugs are on programs that offer like $500 mediums and $1,000 highs.
And I just find, I just find a lot of them and I kind of churn through, churn through smaller programs.
And every once in a while I find a, a really good program.
That's, that's very high paying and I'll spend a long time there.
Um, to kind of become a, an anchor hacker there.
Um, but I've got a, I think, I think if you look, I think hacker one has the ability to show you your average bounty.
And like my average, my average bounty is like only like $700.
Um, and so I submit a lot of, a lot of $500 mediums and a lot of $1,000 highs.
Um, and so, and those are over the, like over a huge spread of, of, of programs.
You know, I'm not like, I think I was talking to, to, um, to some hackers a while back and they're like, yeah, I've probably submitted bugs to, you know, 30 or so different programs.
Like I think I'm like close to like two or 300 different programs that I've, I've submitted bugs to.
Wow.
Yeah.
Just nuts.
Because I just, I just spend time on the, on the small ones and I just kind of like churn through the, submit one or two and, uh, and move on.
So maybe, um, maybe I'm taking the quick and easy route, but it's, uh, it's been working well.
Wow.
Super interesting.
That's, that's really cool.
So I guess that, you know, with moving so quickly, you know, you've got this, this three hour time limit, you get to the end of that three hours.
Let's say you haven't found anything.
Is that a hard stop for you normally or?
Usually.
And I'd say three hours and I said, I said three hours in my, in my tweet, I said three hours.
If it's a smaller program and a smaller scope, it's not going to be three hours.
You know, if it's a WordPress site, I'm not going to spend three hours trying to break WordPress.
Yeah.
Um, but like on the most complicated application.
If I get to, if I get to three hours, I should, I should backtrack and say outside of the context of a live event where I am being paid an ass.
And, and asked to spend, you know, spend time on one particular program.
Mm-hmm .
It's like, okay, if, uh, if I get to three hours and I haven't found anything, I'm usually not going to, to find something unless I.
You know, put in another like 10 at that point, I finally might be able to start finding things.
But like I said, I go through, I go through a lot of, a lot of small programs.
And so if I haven't found anything after three hours, you know, I'd rather move on to a smaller program where I can find something in.
You know, an hour.
Um, and it just kind of keeps me motivated.
That, that's, that's absolutely crazy to me, man.
Like I spend so much more time on, on an actual like target before I move along.
If I don't, I probably will spend 20 hours, maybe three, four hacking sessions on a target without finding a bug.
If I, if I think this is a high value target, but I guess I will say I do typically go for the programs with the higher payouts though.
Yep.
So that's really impressive to me that you're able to find bugs that, you know, in that three hours.
And Joel, I mean, do you, I mean, where, where do you lie in that?
In that I'm curious.
Well, I was, I was going to ask two questions about that.
So for me, I'm like kind of in the middle on that where I'll spend a decent amount of time hacking and I try to identify attack surface and decide sort of as I'm going, whether or not this attack surface is something that I want to spend a ton of time on.
Because if it's something that seems small, like, I don't know if I've seen, if I'm hacking on something and it's just one GraphQL API endpoint and it's not a particularly large GraphQL.
And I start poking at it and I don't see any real red flags.
Yeah. I'm sure there's probably some bugs hidden in there, but I'm not sure how much more time I'm going to go spend on that program.
If I see that they have systemic security measures that aren't like, yeah, they, they, I'm sure there are again, areas where it's not, you know, perfect.
Perfectly airtight, but that is not necessarily like if I want to make a, you know, farm a program or something like, and I see something that's secured, I'm not going to spend a bunch more time on that.
Cause I want to make some money. I want to optimize my time there.
Yeah. I was curious if you spend, you know, whatever your time limit on a program and then you find nothing and you hit your no bug limit.
What comes next? You, you know, say you've been hacking for, you know, you just started, you spent three hours. Okay. You've been going for three hours. You found nothing. You just hit your no bug limit.
What do you do for the rest of the day? Do you just stop hacking or what, what do you have like a backup plan?
Uh, yeah. I mean, usually if, if it's in one day, usually I'll stop. I'm, I, I rare outside of the context of a little event where I'm, you know, basically treating bug bounty as a full-time job.
Um, I'll, I'll stop for the day. I can't, I can't hack for more than three hours in, in one day. Um, unless I happen to start like in the morning and then I have some time like seven hours later in the evening.
Um, I'm not gonna make a face. Like I can't hack for less than three hours.
Are you kidding me right now, dude? Like you telling me that you never, you very rarely hack for longer than three hour contiguous periods.
Yeah, that's, yeah, that's pretty, I get, I get so tired.
Oh my God.
My eyes hurt, man.
Dude, this guy's a beast. This guy is an absolute beast. I could never, I would never find anything.
Oh, so the other thing I wanted to ask was like, you mentioned that except for like for live hacking events, like, you normally have like a no bug limit and then you stop hacking or move on or whatever.
Uh, what does that look like for a live hacking event in terms of success rate? Do you find that it's better to spend the time and just keep pushing on that target?
Even if you pass your no bug limit or, uh, do you find better success?
Uh, so I, yes, in a live hacking event, I think that the targets are much, much deeper.
Um, and the payouts are much, much higher than my typical three K programs.
And so, yeah, I'll, I'll spend, I'll spend a lot more time.
Like for example, if it's, uh, um, you know, like there was an event in Austin last year and it was, um, uh, it was on, it was GitHub, you know, and it took me like three hours just to get GitHub enterprise server set up.
It's like, okay, so yeah.
Yeah.
Easily.
So I'm going to, I'm going to spend more time in the context of a live hacking event where there's much higher payouts and much deeper complex applications.
Um, but live hacking events are, are only a small portion of the year.
And so the rest of the year, I'm just trying to maximize my time.
Like you were talking about Joel and just kind of churn through, churn through programs and, uh, and find the, find the best, uh, time for money, uh, uh, balance.
Wow.
That's, that's really cool.
I, I definitely have not done very much program churning and I've got like, you know, 500 freaking invites sitting there that I, I need to, you know, that I've never even looked at.
So I feel like maybe I should, should go through and just, you know, hit them real fast.
Maybe even bring it down to like, you know, well, actually, I mean, you got it.
You said 30 minutes even for the first initial assessment.
So maybe I'll, I'll hit them 30 minutes, 30 minutes, 30 minutes, 30 minutes, and see if they've got some interesting features.
And especially when, you know, you've got those programs that are like, like 5k crits, you know, or like, you know, 6k or 7k, you know, those are not your big, you know, 40k crits or, or whatever from some of these other programs.
But, but they still like are pretty good, you know?
And so I think there's definitely some, some, you know, really good monetary opportunity for those programs, especially for someone like me, who's a full-time, full-time hunter.
Okay.
So let's go back to the tweet.
Next one that I wanted to talk about, and this kind of ties in was the match and replace rules.
You say, quote, 13, use match and replace rules to find new endpoints.
Now I use match and replace rules for lots of things.
I think a lot of the top hackers do.
And I'm wondering how, I'm interested by the fact that you said to find new endpoints.
So could you tell me exactly how that works for you?
Sure. Yeah.
So I am kind of a dummy and don't know how to use .NET to find new endpoints.
Like, I don't, I don't know how that works.
And so, so to think I have to have the application find endpoints for me.
And so I'll notice in the responses to a lot of requests, usually like when I load a, like the application initially, it will like the, like, you'll say like, get user slash user info.
And it'll be like, is admin false in the, like the JSON response.
I'm like, okay, something on the JavaScript side, because I don't understand JavaScript at all is using that, that response body to populate the, populate the page.
And so I'll just, you know, make a match and replace rule that's like, is admin true?
I think there was like one application a while back that had like, like 15 different Boolean roles.
And I was like, just like added them all.
Like is, is what true?
Is blank true?
And it made the, you know, the UI a disgusting mess, but it gave me access to different parts of the application that I would be able to find if I knew how to actually read JavaScript.
So that's kind of, that's kind of what I do.
Dude, that was, that was my follow up question.
Cause I wanted to know, like, do that end dude, or do you, are you doing like a lot of static analysis and that kind of stuff to also find the endpoints?
Cause I liked that approach that you mentioned.
That's like, why would I find the endpoints when I could let the application find the endpoints?
And I think that is definitely the case a lot of the time with JavaScript, where oftentimes the bundles for other pages or hidden, hidden stuff that you wouldn't normally be seeing, or you might not know is there, is still getting pulled down by the client.
And you can see a lot of that if you, if you, you know, dive into it and take a little bit of a closer look, but it's, it sounds like you're pretty much just like, you know, let the application actually show me it.
He's just raw dog in the match of replace right there.
Yeah.
I'm sure, I'm sure I would, I'm sure I'll find more bugs and I eventually get around to learning how to, how to hack.
But, um,
Yeah.
So that, that's cool though.
And I think for any, any of, any of the people out there that are listening that don't know how to assess JavaScript files, you know, uh, Douglas is at every live hacking event and he does great.
And he's very much a valued member of this community.
And so he's up at the top and he has got there even without knowing how to find endpoints in JavaScript files, which for, to me, to be honest, is like kind of crazy.
Like I, that is such a core part of my methodology and also something that I teach at a very early stage to new hackers.
Um, so the fact that you've done this well without ever doing that is like, there's some sort of secret sauce in there that I need, you know, and maybe it's just the match and replace, but either way, it's, it's very impressive, man.
Um,
Yep.
I'm like, I'm like a bow hunter who, who knows that I could, you know, hunt further with a, with a rifle, but I just, uh, never, never, never learned how to use one.
Um, so one of the ones you mentioned, we'll go a little bit out of order here, but the number 76 says that if the app uses intercom, which intercom is like the little support bubble, like chat, chat with us thing in the bottom.
Um, then you say, try booting it with another email.
What does that mean?
What is that?
Is that like for account confusion and stuff?
Yeah.
So, so intercom is really interesting in that there is, there's a concept called identity verification.
Uh, and they even write an entire article on how to do it.
But the thing is that intercom widgets are typically set up by sales teams and they might not be the most technical and, or they might just be lazy.
Um, and so what happens often is I say maybe like 20% of the time you just see the intercom widget.
And what you can do is just open up your, your console in the browser and just type like intercom, uh, open print boot.
And then email and then give it some other email and then enter.
And it will basically start up the intercom widget as if you were logged in as, um, as the user with that email.
So I'll usually try like email test at test.com.
And usually there's been some sales person that's registered on the application with test at test.com.
And you'll be able to see their, see their, um, their chats that they've had.
Um, in fact, it's super interesting.
Yeah.
So I wrote a blog about this.
Um, and there was a, uh, because there was a hacker one, there's a third party hacker one vendor that, um, uh, that did just this.
And basically as a result, I was able to, uh, view like social security information of any hacker because, because I could, I could log into any other hackers, uh, account on this third party using the intercom widget.
And then their password reset functionality was just like resetting it to, I think like winter 22 bang or something.
What?
Yeah.
So they give you like a hard coded temp password and just be like, Hey, I'm Ryan Raider.
Um, I want to know where he lives.
I want to know his, you know, his social security number.
And then he'd be like, okay, here's your new password.
Wow.
Oh my God.
Crazy.
Yeah.
Uh, I, I, I missed somehow, I thought I went through all of the things on your blog, but I somehow I missed this dude.
And I'm looking at it right now.
This is from 2021.
Um, November 3rd is when he released it.
Yeah.
This is hilarious.
You've got, you're like, it literally says they respond back and say, use the temporary password summer at one, two, three.
Oh, wow.
Yeah.
Which by the way, your blog is, is awesome.
D day.us.
Yeah.
Um, yeah, there's so many really, uh, really cool blog posts there.
That's awesome.
We'll definitely, we'll definitely link those.
Um, that's one that I've never heard of and I'm definitely going to be on the lookout for.
Yeah.
Intercom is everywhere.
Um, so I'm kicking myself right now because I can't even imagine how many of those I've, you know, slid straight by.
Yep.
Yeah.
Without ever talking about it.
Just, just earlier today I found a, a, a random application that I was hacking on and was using intercom.
They, they were, they were secure.
They were using, uh, identity verification, but yeah.
And say probably like maybe 10 to 20% of the time you'll, you'll just be able to boot into someone else's chats and see their, see their chats.
I've probably made about like $10,000 with that buck over the course of, over the course of the last couple of years.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's crazy, man.
I know you said that most of them were really like original tips that were like new ideas.
Uh, some of these were like definitely more like, uh, you buy it on a sign at home goods.
Yeah.
It's like, be thankful for failure.
Okay.
No, no, no.
That, that one's a great one.
And I, I put that on there for a reason because it's great.
It's great.
I've just, or live, laugh, love.
I couldn't.
Exactly.
No, you need like, we need like, uh, you know, home goods, bug bounty edition, right?
Yeah.
No, I thought this was a really good one though, because I, uh, this is something that I talk about all the time, which is like, if you're, especially if you're getting into bug bounty or you're training in bug bounty, um, you should be thankful for those, those, those, those fails.
You know, you're, you're, you're getting out there.
And I think this is also very similar to the other one, which is, um, uh, 30 number 30 on your list, which is pin your success on whether you followed your plan.
Not if you found bugs.
Right.
So I think those go together really well.
Um, and, and that, you know, even if you're, if you're, if you're saying, all right, I'm going to test these, this features, this asset.
And so on and so forth, if you were able to focus on that, even if you're failing, you're getting your reps in, you're, you're figuring out what attack vectors don't work.
You're getting your, you're training your intuition for this target and you're getting closer and closer and closer to the, to the next, uh, to the next bug.
Right.
I mean, is that, was that what you had in mind when you wrote these?
Yeah, exactly.
Because like, you, you know, you think like, okay, I'm hacking on a, on a, on a program for during a live hacking event.
Uh, I've put in the reps, I've tested, you know, X asset for five hours.
Like there are other hackers that are going to also be testing that same asset for five hours and finding and finding nothing.
And so you finding, you know, you spending the time and not finding anything is just getting that out of the way.
Just like everybody else is going.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
This reminds me a lot of, uh, uh, thread that you did, Justin, um, a couple months ago about, I think it was about a, uh, Heberman lab episode.
Uh, that was talking about motivation and why, like you, you shouldn't reward yourself or you shouldn't like, uh, discipline yourself.
If you fail, basically, even if you're holding to your plan, like, and you don't find anything, for example, right?
Bug bounty is not pay for effort.
It's pay for results, which is something that we say a lot, like all the time.
And the reality is that if you spend a bunch of time and you find nothing, don't discipline yourself and be like, oh God, I'm so bad at hacking.
Cause you didn't find anything because it's not pay for effort.
It's pay for results.
And just cause you didn't find anything doesn't mean that you're a bad hacker.
Like you learned a lot from, from that time, just like the time with the scope and looking at the target and learning new things.
Like there, it's still very, very valuable.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I think this is especially true when you're, when you're learning, but it's even, it's even true when you're more experienced as well, because every app is different.
Right.
And, and so all of us are just learning these apps that we're, we're going into hack.
Um, so I think, I think that's, that's some good, some good sage wisdom from, from a bug bounty uncle Douglas day here.
And then the next one can actually go on a, on a, on a little poster, which is there is no end.
Enjoy the journey.
Talk to me a little bit about that one.
Give me your thoughts on that one.
Yeah.
So I think like it was, it was really easy.
It was really fun.
Um, starting bug bounty because I didn't have necessarily some end goal that I was going after.
I was just like, I'm trying to figure out, figure this out.
Maybe I'll eventually get to go to a live hacking event.
And then I think as soon as you submit a report, I got to talk about, about my first report on this episode.
Um, but, uh, but, but no, I mean, it's, there's, there's always going to be bugs.
You're always going to be hacking.
There's not like, there's, there's no finish line.
And so I think you'll just start to get depressed.
If you still feel like you're X number of bugs away from a finish line, you just kind of gotta just keep going.
Cause it's not going to stop until, until you do.
I mean, eventually I'll get to a point where I'm like, okay, I've, I've done enough and I'll, and I'll hang up the keyboard and, you know, sit on my porch with a shotgun on my latch on that.
Oh my God.
You know, I'm at least a couple months away from that point.
So.
Nice.
Well, so.
Go ahead, Joel.
Yeah.
Why don't you talk a little bit about that?
Cause that sounds like more of the like peaceful life of the life side of like away from keyboards.
So how do you, how do you do that balance?
You mentioned that you only hack like three hours a day, um, and all that kind of stuff.
I imagine part of that is cause you have a family obviously, and there's, you know, family responsibilities and obligations and all that kind of stuff.
How do you do that balance of the back and forth?
Oh goodness.
This is a big question.
Um, so I remember hitting my sort of meteoric rise and bug bounty right around the time.
I started getting invited to lots of hacking events ahead of getting basically on the live event train two years after starting bug bounty was.
It was awesome financially, but it also created a really like weird expectation in my mind that in order for me to have a hobby, it had to be income generating.
And dude, yeah.
And so if like, I couldn't, I felt like I couldn't justify doing anything.
I couldn't justify hanging out with friends.
Cause I'm like, man, if I, I could do bug bounty and I could make, you know, X number of thousands of dollars, or I could hang with, hang out with my friends and make zero dollars.
So maybe it kind of shoot.
It feels like hanging out with my buddy is costing me, you know, $2,000 because I'm not finding a critical tonight and good.
Dude, that's a very profound way of saying it actually.
Like I had not ever put it into words, but like, I don't know why I got so addicted to, to it, you know?
And I was like, man, why, why am I not pursuing other hobbies?
And I came, you know, came to the same conclusion a different way, but to hear you say it's costing me $2,000 to hang out with my buddy.
Yeah, it's opportunity cost.
Yup.
That's, that's deep, man.
Yeah.
And so you end up just kind of like being a shadow version of yourself where you're not able to justify.
doing anything that isn't, isn't productive.
And you kind of get like hooked on this, on this productivity grind set.
And yeah, I, I went through a very long time where I was just not able to enjoy, enjoy life.
And yeah, I mean, I don't know what to say other than you just, you have to have something that you do.
That's, that's for fun and, and try to like, I try to frame it.
Like the, it's kind of like the, the engine oil to my, my car.
That is myself.
It's like, yeah, engine oil.
Isn't going to run the gate.
Isn't going to run or isn't going to get me from point A to point B.
Just like hanging out with friends and playing board games, isn't going to make me money, but it's also going to make sure that my car doesn't break.
So that it can get from point A to point B and it's, you know, having, having a social life and having hobbies is going to make sure that I don't, you know, break down and just.
Yeah.
Not, uh, lose all motivation to, to hack.
So.
Well, the, the, the listeners here know how, how I am with analogies, but I'm going to, I'm going to take an attempt here to take this a little bit further.
And you can even, just hold on.
Just, just, just, just.
Let him cook.
All right.
Okay.
You know, you said that this is the oil, right?
Mm-hmm.
Hanging out with friends is the oil.
And then, you know, you're in the car, but the, the point of the car is to get you to the destination.
Right.
And I think we can even, we can even talk about this in, in a bigger picture, which is all of this, I guess it, it, it, it's to a destination of, you know, or you could say money in general or earning in general is to this destination of creating this lifestyle that you want, or this lifestyle that you need to, to do your, live your life.
And, and, you know, it could be generosity.
It could be, you know, getting the new hot tub you want to sit in.
It could be this or that, whatever our goals are.
Um, you know, those are also keeping those in line and not getting caught up in the little metrics of like, all right, did I make, you know, X tens of thousands of dollars in bugs bounty this month?
Um, that's something that I've found really hard to keep in my, in my, you know, site over the past couple of years of doing poke bounty.
Right.
Yeah.
Cause like no matter, no matter how much you enjoy the work that you're doing, you can't work just to enjoy the time that you're not working.
Like, I think, I think like work is, is very holy.
And so do having, working for the sake of doing like the work itself and do, you know, hacking because you enjoy it and enjoying the actual hacking process and having that be its own ends is, is really important.
Otherwise, like, I mean, yeah, I really enjoy hacking, but if the only reason I'm hacking is so that I can afford a new hot tub and, and better enjoy the time that I'm not hacking, then it's like, what's the point?
Um, so I think there has to be a, a really good, uh, I guess, what am I trying to say?
I think that there is work, work itself, I think is a, needs to be a, a core part of the life, right?
Enjoying it.
It's, are you talking about almost going back to your journey sort of thing here?
You need to enjoy that journey along the way.
Yeah.
It needs, it needs, it can't be just a means to an end.
I think doing bug bounty needs to be something you enjoy.
And I think I've, I've mentored a number of people in bug bounty and it's been kind of clear that their reason for doing it, you know, they see that they see the money that I've made at a live event and they're like, oh shoot, I really, you know, want some money to be able to do whatever.
And it's like, you might be able to do that for a short while, but if you don't enjoy, if you're not like interested in insecurity and you don't like enjoy that puzzle aspect of bug bounty, then you're just doing this for the money.
And it's not going to, it's not going to last and it's not going to stick.
Whereas if you're doing it because you're curious and curious and you really enjoy the, the, the process itself, then, then yeah, it'll, it'll, it'll be a lot more sustainable.
Solid man. Yeah, no, that that's, that's, that's very key.
I think for people to understand in the bug bounty scene, you can't, we always say on the pod as well.
And I, I give this to advice to people that are trying to get into bug bounty.
You can't be doing bug bounty just for the, just for the money of it.
A lot of the time, you know, if you do, there's going to be a lot of things you're going to run up against that you're not going to know how to deal with.
So at the end of the day, it really, really helps for you.
And, and I guess, let me, let me restate that you can, but there, there will be difficulties that will not be there.
If you, if you don't also love, if you also love bug bounty, that that's the way that it goes a lot smoother.
Yeah.
I, I see this extend also into like way more than just bug bounty.
I mean, this is true for every single industry.
There are so many flashy industries that really draw your attention in that want you to like, that make people, you know, drop everything they're doing and go switch industries to go chase that crazy thing.
Like sometimes that works out, but there are a lot of cases where just simply chasing it might get you some money in the short term, but it's not really going to be something that you enjoy doing.
And if you find something that can do both of those things, which bug bounty can be that beautiful intersection for a lot of us, then, then that's an awesome thing to do, but it's not for everybody.
And like, that's why there are tons of people who do purely app sec and no bug bounty, and also people who do tons of bug bounty and no apps.
Right. And there's like so many sides of the spectrum that it just needs to be like something that you enjoy doing and genuinely are having fun with.
And that like, you know, actually satisfies you. Otherwise it's just going to turn into that, that grind where you start to dread it and it's just like not fun anymore. And yeah.
And I think that's where the, the hacker, or not the, I'm sorry, the hacker one, but the bug bounty community in general kind of comes into play because I think that bug bounty, like the bug bounty community is, uh, uh, the bug bounty community is what makes bug bounty enjoyable for me.
It's not just, not just the hacking. It's hanging out with, with people that I've become friends with. Like, uh, hanging out with, uh, with hackers, like, like you guys being on Twitter, being, you know, do this, uh, response. Like, I think, uh, whenever, uh, like he says, like you guys hanging out on Twitter, being do this.
I mean, that's pretty much all we do.
Got him.
So there's kind of like a game that I play. I like to play with, uh, with purely where, uh, Ben, you know, the homestead will like post like a Twitter or a new YouTube episode.
And he's always got some like facial expression, uh, in, in the thumbnail and then to like pure Luke and me will always just like, you know, imitate him and like posted the Twitter thread.
And I mean, dumb things like that to make bug bounty fun. Cause you feel like you're, you feel like you're in a, in a tribe.
Yeah. Yeah. And you are in it and it is a lovely experience and there's all so much lovey dove and touchy feely feelings for the bug bounty community.
But here on critical thinking, we talk about the technical details. So let me, let me, let me, uh, let me get, let me rope it back in.
I have a couple of things before we run out of time that I want to, I want to pick your brain on. Um, and so one of the things that, uh, one of those things is this whole concept of.
Authy testing, you know, creating matrices and stuff like that. So I've seen you go so far as to, you know, build out a little, you know, either a spreadsheet or, or, you know, write it down of how you're testing various roles and permissions and stuff like that.
So could you talk a little bit about that functionality? Yeah. That, uh, that part of your methodology.
So this is something that, that will like, it's very slow and it's not very exciting and it's not very fun, but in the context of a live event where I need to go deep and I need to test for bugs that ever, that other people aren't testing for.
Yeah. I'll go, I'll go so far as to take a list of the roles, um, make a, make a matrix of them, like, and then each kind of like type of functionality. So I'll have like admin, uh, not quite admin, but still high level user, um, read only user and like a knot.
And then I'll have like, uh, uh, inviting users to your org, uh, the writing documents, creating reports, viewing reports, et cetera.
And I'll have a list of like every piece of functionality and then just kind of like go and try to try to figure out what is the, what users should be able to do what, and then find cases where user.
You know, a might be able to do function X, even though according to the documentation, they're, they're not.
And so reading that, like reading the docs, like a really, really good documentation will have this matrix built out for you.
Um, and I, I love it when I, when I encounter that and then you can kind of just go, okay, according to the docs, you just slap right in the report, like, like ammunition.
You're like, according to the docs, this user shouldn't be able to do this.
I can do this.
There's my bug.
Um, and like, they can't, they can't, they can't do this.
They can't, they can't say that it's not a bug.
I mean, occasionally you'll feel like.
I love, I love this part of Douglas.
He's like, and it's in the docs.
And because of that, it's definitely a bug and you can't argue with me.
It's true.
Like occasionally, occasionally you'll see someone who's like, oh, the docs team is, these are outdated docs.
And I mean, I leave the program.
They'll put it in the docs.
Documentation issue.
I know.
But being able to like come like stacked with like ammunition so that the program can't like weasel their way out of.
Of a, of a, of a bounty saying it's like intended functionality.
It's like, no, it can't be intended functionality because it's in the docs.
And I read the docs and I know you haven't.
Do you, do you have like a specific technology that you use to document this?
Or do you actually physically write it down?
Or do you, does it vary from time to time?
Or do you, do you, do you, do you, do you, do you, do you, do you just.
No, no, because it's, I mean, I run into, I, I run into.
Dying.
It was like, I'm sorry.
What?
Not color coded.
Like what?
Yeah.
I mean, do you, do you color code stuff?
Do you, do you just.
No, no, because it's, I mean, I run into.
I run into.
Dying.
It was like, I'm sorry.
What?
Not color coded.
Like what?
Yeah.
Just give me a link.
I'll come in and fix it.
Yeah.
But yeah, it's a, yeah.
Our, our back thing.
It's a, it's really helpful when you're, when you really need to go deep and you need to find,
to find bugs, because I mean, these things can't be fixed systematically or programmatically.
It's like they, all these endpoints, they need to be properly scoped.
And oftentimes, especially when new roles are added over time, it's going to be a real developer pain to have to.
Yeah.
Try to scope every single one of these endpoints.
Um, I think one of my, like one of my highest paid programs is a very small, like 3k crit program, $500 mediums.
And I've submitted, I think like a hundred different like reports on this one program.
I think I've made like 60 K or on this, on this program.
Just like in like $500.
$500 bugs.
Yeah.
It just tons and tons and tons of them.
It's just, it's, it's just going through each of these endpoints and finding, uh, where, where this, uh, you know, where users are able to call endpoints that they shouldn't be able to call.
And it really helps that in this particular program, it lets you build custom roles.
And so you, not only is it like that you have the, you know, like three or four given roles, it's like, I can make a role that has this permission and this permission, but not this permission.
Um, and so that's, uh, that's usually.
I'm sure that gets super complicated.
You know, once, once you have the ability to make custom roles and stuff like that, whatever spreadsheet you're, you're using gets probably crazy looking.
Yep.
Exactly.
And what's, what's really fun is when the, the program like fixes it with like a V2 API, but doesn't turn off the V1 API.
Oh my gosh.
No.
And then she's like, Hey, you can still do this by using the V1 API.
And then, you know, ah,
I'm curious if you feel like, does it ever feel like gamifying the system or like, um, how often do you find that report or that programs will close?
Like if you submit one report per endpoint or something, how often will they close at all as one fix?
That's a good question.
So kind of going back to how I, I go through, I turned through a lot of small programs.
Um, one, uh, one thing, one of my strategies or methodologies is I'll put out like little canary reports or like dealer reports, or I'll submit like two reports.
So important to a brand new program and just see, see how they're handled.
So for example, I got invited to a, a program like, uh, about a month ago.
Um, and it was a pretty, like, looked like a pretty good program, not too many, too much activity, but pretty big application.
Uh, went and found, um, like two, like decently impactful IDORs, um, on, on the app, um, within my, you know, three hour window.
And I submitted them and, uh, I'm still, uh, I think I submitted them 28 days ago and I'm still waiting for the bounty.
And, uh, yeah, I'm like, okay.
So it's not a good sign.
It was easy to find the bugs, but I'm not sure I want to wait, you know, a month to get, to get, to get paid.
So I just kind of, you know, even though there's probably bugs to be, to, uh, to find, I'm, I'm probably not going to come and swing around, uh, to find more bugs there.
Hmm. Yeah, that makes sense. And, and so I guess going back to the, the methodology piece, there's, and, and we actually kind of talked about this a little bit before, because there will be an episode coming out.
Eventually it's in our, it's in our, uh, emergency episode, you know, sort of backlog of like, if for some reason we can't record one week, then we'll, we'll send out this video.
But essentially, uh, I wanted to talk about this, this concept of nose in the application that you talk about in your NahamSec talk.
I loved this when I saw it, it really resounded with me and it really, um, I think sets up a good framework for how to identify vulnerabilities in an application.
Um, so could you talk a little bit about that?
Yeah, so this is my, it's kind of like one of my favorite things, uh, because when I, I've taught a lot of people or maybe like five to 10 people how to, how to bug bounty hunt.
And the most common reaction I get is, wait, that's a, that's a bug.
Cause I think when people think about bug bounty hunting, they're thinking about like authentication bypasses, like being able to like log, like log in as any user.
They're thinking about RCEs or, uh, SQL injections or squillies as I call them.
Um, Oh no.
Oh God.
You don't, you don't fit squilly.
No, get off the podcast.
Yeah.
You leave right now.
We got this far and then he had to say that.
He had to say squillies.
Like, oh geez.
Squillies.
Yeah.
So, uh, but no, I'll be like, I'll be finding these, these bugs that are like, yeah, this, this read only user can perform some action that, that.
Does a, a right.
Um, and they'll be like, but who cares?
I'm like, but I care and the program cares because they, they specifically set this trust boundary and we are breaching that trust boundary.
And they're like, but that's, that's a security bug.
And I'm like, yeah.
Like if, if I, as a, as an application don't want some user to be doing something, if I'm telling them, no, you can't write.
You can't write, you can only read than any, any time that user can write.
That's a, that's a security vulnerability.
And so just thinking with that mindset of where is the application, where, where has the application been designed and configured to not let me do something in every single one of those is an opportunity for a bug.
Um, nice.
And that's kind of just how I, how I approach really any application.
Um, so, um, yeah.
Yeah.
That those, those having those sort of frameworks, I think for me, my methodology has sort of, uh, evolved over the years in a very intuitive sort of way.
Like, and as I, as I'm kind of coming into the content creation scene, I'm trying to figure out how do I put these into frameworks?
And I love it when you get a nice, simple, clean framework, like what you just described to help you identify stuff.
Just open, open the app, look for the nose.
Look for the places where you should be, you know, where, where the application is telling you, you can't do something.
Look for it in the documentation, look for it in the grayed out buttons, look for it, you know, all over the place.
Right.
And, uh, and take those and, and try to try to exploit those.
Yeah.
I really liked that.
And, and I think, uh, I think sometimes those, those sort of, sort of bugs can get, um, I guess, like you mentioned, they're not the squillies.
Mm-hmm .
They're not the RCEs, but they do have a lot of impact, uh, time sometimes.
And sometimes they're just a violation of the trust boundary.
And that's something that the, that the team wants to clean up.
Yeah.
It's not our responsibility necessarily to define what threat model a company has.
It's, it's our responsibility to find the bugs that violate the company's threat model.
Um, and so that's what we do.
Yep.
Exactly.
I think that's a really good way of like mapping out like the, uh, the threat model, which is like a really difficult thing to do.
We've talked about this a bunch where it's super difficult, both from the program side and the hacker side to, from the hacker side to identify what the threat model is supposed to be.
And from this, from the security team side to explain what, how the security team is approaching the threat model when a bug comes in.
And so I think you can sort of find those hard stops essentially where like, oh, in the documentation, it says this or in the app, it does a certain thing.
Or there are these certain limitations that are in place that tell me this is where the threat model is.
This is the barrier.
If you can get around this, then this is something that's hard, like hard to find.
Exactly.
And I like what Justin said about grayed out buttons.
That's kind of another, another big telltale sign, especially when you can just like right click and spec element and then turn, you know, enable it.
Boom.
Yeah.
Nice.
I love that dude.
The classic.
Yeah.
So, so one more thing that I wanted to talk about before we wrap it up, uh, and that is the sort of mapping your hacking sessions blog posts that you put out, um, in 2021.
I really liked this.
Once again, it's a good, it's a good framework.
It's a good practice for bug bounty hunting.
Uh, tell us a little bit about that and how that's affected your, your bug bounty hunting.
Yes.
This is, this is approach.
I typically go, I go with after I've taken a fair bit of time off of hacking or maybe after I've just come off of a long hacking event where I'm, I come off and then I'm not sure what to hack on.
And that kind of that decision paralysis.
So, ah, I have so many options available.
I've got like hundreds of private programs, hundreds of public programs.
I don't, I don't know what to hack on.
And then I, I like the cost of context switching is just so high in bug bounty.
Cause you're like, it is man.
You could, you could spend, you know, half an hour on, you know, program a, and then like the entire time you're hacking on program a, you're like, oh man, is my, is my time better spent over on program B.
Am I just like wasting, wasting time here?
I don't know.
Or target B or, you know, or scope item B, you know.
Exactly.
And then you end up just kind of like second guessing yourself.
And then maybe you like, you give up too, like too early and you're like, okay, I'm actually going to hack on, you know, program B or asset B.
Whereas, you know, if you would have only, if you would have spent another 15 minutes on, on asset A, you would have found a bug.
And so just creating like the, the concept of mapping your hacking is just creating a rule, like a predefined rule when you're in a clear space, a clear mind where you're like, okay, I'm going to spend one hour hacking on GitHub.
And I'm going to, you know, I'm going to try to mess with the, the GitHub CLI and see if I can't modify issues that I, I don't have access to.
And then after, after that one hour or two hours or whatever, whatever it is, that's, you've already given yourself permission to switch, to switch scope.
And this decision, the decision's already been made for you.
And so you don't have that hanging over your head the entire time you're hacking.
And so really, I guess the, the essence of that methodology is just pre it's just making the decisions beforehand when you're in a, in a clear and not stressed out state of mind.
Because yeah, that's, that's, I love that view.
I mean, that's like the best way to make failure, like failure case things so that you're basically ready for failure.
Yep.
I think a lot of people will start to, to shift the goalpost over time.
Um, when they hit failure, they'll be like, okay, well, let me just give it two more hours or let me keep, keep going until I find at least one thing or whatever.
And that, that'll just keep going.
Why are you looking at me, Joel?
Wait, wait.
How did you know?
Yeah.
But, but like, I think that's like a really common trope to fall into.
And if instead, like you said, like if you set those hard deadlines and you plan ahead of time, okay, if I fail in this amount of time, then I'm, I'm setting guardrails for myself so that I, I don't just keep shifting the goalposts.
Like I go and I do something else and it's not just like a constant, like you fail harder and harder.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
And you can feel good.
Like, even if you didn't find any bugs, you can be like, I executed the plan and next, uh, you know, next time I'm going to set, you know, I'm going to map it this way and then I'm going to execute again.
And then, I mean, we've, we've, we've done bug about, you know, all of us here, I've done bug about too long enough that we all know the bugs are there.
There's never, like, it's never a case of there aren't bugs to find.
There are always bugs to find.
It's just a matter of going until you find them.
Um, and if you just keep mapping your hacking session, you'll, and you keep executing on the plan, then you'll have success.
After success, after success, after success.
And then eventually the successful also include a bug.
So you, I think one of your superpowers as a hacker is your consistency and your, I guess, disciplined-ness, you know, with these frameworks and with these ways, ways to approach targets and these rules.
And, and I really liked what you mentioned just a second ago when you're having been hacking for a little while and you've got this sort of like restart anxiety, right.
Um, going into it, it's very real.
And you've got a plan to, you've got a, a, you know, a counter plan to, to get over it.
Um, I'm, I want to ask though, how often do you follow your own advice here?
How often do you do this?
Give me, give me a rough percentage of times when you actually do what you are talking about.
Um, I'd say most of the time during, in, in the situations where I have scheduled my hacking.
If there are many, many, many times where I'll just be like in the middle of like, you know, doing some other thing that isn't hacking and a brand new program invite will come.
And it's just like, boom, boom, boom, rush, rush, rush, rush, rush.
Um, you know, that those rules that I set don't really apply there because it's about, you know, it's exciting.
I've kind of like, I'm brought into it without, or I'm brought into a hacking mindset without, uh, without having time to like map my hacking.
I'm just like, okay, it's brand new program.
Let's give it a shot.
Um, similar, similarly with, um, with, uh, currently get like other situations.
Um, maybe someone will like come to like, someone will ping me and they'll be like, Hey, you know, Douglas, can you, can you look at this?
Or, um, I'm in a couple of discord groups.
We'll just all collectively decide, Oh, we're going to all hack on, hack on, you know, program X.
It's like, okay, I'm not going to make everyone stop so that we can, you know, schedule out and map our, our hacking session.
We're just going to hack against it.
But during the, during the moments or during the times of the week where I'm like, I'm going to hack from, you know, 8 PM until 10 PM, or I'm going to hack until, you know, from Saturday morning at 9 AM until noon.
Those like scheduled hacking, hacking times are where I, I will follow my own advice.
Wow.
That's, that's pretty, that's pretty crazy, man.
That, that on a regular, cause like, even when I have scheduled hacking time, I, I think sometimes I just sit down and I just kind of play around with stuff, you know, and, and, and maybe that's, that's inefficient.
But, um, you know, yeah, that, that's pretty impressive to hear that most of the times when you're actually sitting down intentionally hacking, right.
Um, that you're actually getting that, that done.
Yeah.
And I'm not perfect, but I think a lot of it has to do with, I, I have less, like I have a family and I have less free time to hack than, than the average, like bachelor or bachelor.
Yeah, average, uh, uh, no kids full-time bounty hunter.
Yeah, exactly.
So it's like, okay, my, my, you know, Tuesday evening from 8 PM until 10 PM.
And my Saturday morning from 8 AM until noon, like those are like my hanging hours.
Those, you know, those things six out, there's like my six hours of that week that I get to have solid hacking time.
I want to be able to like capitalize and maximize on those.
And I also know that they're coming ahead of time, so it's not, and so it's, it's, it's easier to, to be more disciplined when it's a very limited amount of time.
And I know ahead of time when it's happening.
Very cool, man.
Very nice.
Well, that, that is the, that is the summary of all of the technique related questions I have for you.
Um, we are getting pretty far along in time.
Joel, did you have anything else you wanted to add it before we close up?
I think we've exhausted everything except for Douglas's social security number from him.
So yeah, exactly.
Which maybe we can get with an intercom book.
Yeah.
Like, like let's just see boot intercom.
No, that's great.
Well, thanks for coming on the pod.
It's been a pleasure having you on.
And, and it's, you know, like you said, it's a, it's a pleasure always hanging out with you at the live hacking events and being part of the community together.
So yeah, I appreciate you making time for it.
Yeah.
I appreciate you guys having me on.
And, uh, as always, I'm looking forward to listening to the podcast.
I did have one other question.
I know, I know you guys don't call SQL eyes squillies, but you do at least call RCEs Ricky's right?
Oh my God.
All right.
That's it.
Cut it.
Cut it now.